Well, good morning again, church.
Can I say you're looking pretty good this morning?
I don't know what's different today.
I don't know something about that.
But, uh, as we dress up to honor the end of a sermon series
that we've called, he Shall Reign.
That does mean we're coming to the end of First Samuel.
And it's just been such an incredible
study for me personally.
I've grown in my affection and knowledge of Jesus and,
and just has been stirring my soul in many ways,
has challenged me in a lot of ways.
And so I'm thankful, uh, that
as we've watched Israel struggle with whether they're going
to allow God to be king
or not, that we've learned a lot about ourselves in
that I pray that we have yet, as much as God was against it
for Israel, choosing to want a king, he was still gracious
to them and kept them
and preserved his people, even through the many failures
of Saul, their first king.
And, and, and,
and God was bringing about the second King David anointing
him and the whole process of how that worked out.
Well today, as we reach the end of one Samuel,
is the final step in that transition from Dave, from Saul
to David as King of Israel.
Uh, we've been seeing this build for, for months now.
As we've walked through one Samuel, we've seen piece
by piece how, uh, from the beginning
with Samuel helping transition from judges to kings, then
to Saul being the king and popular and then declining
and David rising in popularity.
We've seen this all building.
Well, today is the final battle.
This is the final step, the last step for Saul,
where all the prophecies become fulfilled.
And so we're gonna turn to the end of one Samuel chapter 31.
That's where we'll be today.
The last chapter one, Samuel 31.
I'm just gonna read the whole thing. It's only 13 verses
to give us the picture of what happens here
and then we'll come back, work through it.
One Samuel 31.
Now the Philistines were fighting against Israel
and the men of Israel fled before the Philistines
and fell slain on Mount Gilboa.
And the Philistines overtook Saul and his sons,
and the Philistines struck down Jonathan and Abab
and Mal Kahua, the sons of Saul.
The battle pressed hard against Saul
and the archers found him,
and he was badly wounded by the archers.
And Saul said to his armor bearer, draw your sword
and thrust me through with it, lest these uncircumcised come
and thrust me through and mistreat me.
But his armor bearer would not for he feared greatly.
Therefore, Saul took his own sword and fell upon it.
And when his armor bearers, saw that Saul was dead,
he also fell upon his sword and died with him.
Thus, Saul died and his three sons and his armor bearer
and all his men on the same day together, when the men
of Israel who were on the other side of the valley
and those beyond the Jordan saw that the men
of Israel had fled and that Saul and his sons were dead.
They abandoned their cities and fled,
and the Philistines came and lived in them.
The next day when the Philistines came to strip the slain,
they found Saul and his three sons fallen on Mount Gilboa.
So they cut off his head and stripped off his armor
and sent messengers throughout the land of the Philistines
to carry the good news to the house
of their idols and to the people.
They put his armor in the temple of aov,
they fastened his body to the wall of Besson.
But when the inhabitants of Jbe, Gilead heard
what the Philistines had done to Saul,
all the valiant men arose
and went all night, took the body of Saul, the body
of his sons from the wall of Betson.
They came to Jesh and burned them there,
and they took their bones and buried them under the tamaris
tree in Jesh and fasted seven days.
God, this is your word as often hard as it is to
see and read.
We pray that you, your spirit would speak through it today,
that we would see clearly what we need to see, what we need
to learn to be hearers of the word,
but also to be doers of the word more importantly,
and that you would teach us Holy Spirit, what you want us to
remember and, and discover here,
and how you want to transform us
more into the image of Jesus.
We pray that you would. In Jesus' name we pray. Amen.
So here's the plan for today. As we walk through this.
The whole of one Samuel has been this contrast
between Saul and David, right?
So we're gonna see Saul, we're gonna work through this.
Then we're gonna come back to David A. Little bit,
even though David doesn't show up here in the chapter.
We're gonna come back to David, pick up some things
that we can learn from there.
But also, since one Samuel is intended
to point our minds forward to the Messiah,
we're gonna come back and,
and discover how the Messiah, we know Jesus Christ,
how he is the actual perfect king that we need.
So with three steps, we're gonna look at Saul,
then we're gonna look at David, and
then we'll come back to Jesus.
So hang with me if you get a little lost
or some struggle here, like we'll get
to Jesus here at the end.
And so first we're gonna start with Saul.
This chapter describes his tragic end.
His tragic end.
Last week we looked at how Saul's life is a tragedy.
It's something that was just almost impossible
to think about could have ever happened.
This man falls from the heights.
He fell to the role in, in the end of his life that he,
even the night before this moment of his last battle,
he's meeting with this necromancer, this spirit woman
who was illegal in the land
that he had even kicked out before.
But he, he is such a desperate man that he's looking
for answers in all the wrong places.
He's breaking God's commands, his law to find answers.
That's how far he's fallen, which leads to
what we see here in chapter 31.
This final fulfillment of what God had told Saul
multiple times through Samuel, through other God said
to Saul, you're going to die soon.
Here. It happens. But let's consider why this
was such a tragic death.
Why? Why is this so tragic?
First, it's that Saul died instead of defeated.
Saul died instead of defeated.
Now I realize the grammar's a little funky there.
So let me get to explaining that. What, what I mean by that?
What, what do I mean? So, so think back to chapter nine.
The first time that Saul was chosen to be the king,
God told Samuel something about Saul
that would define his life.
So listen to this. This is first Samuel chapter nine,
verse 16.
God said to Samuel, tomorrow about this time, I'll send
to you a man from the land of Benjamin.
You shall anoint him to be the prince
or king over my people, Israel.
He shall save my people from the hand of the Philistines,
for I've seen my people because their cry has come to me.
That was the original mandate for Saul, was
to defeat the Philistines.
Yet what happens here in chapter 31, he's defeated
by the Philistines, right?
That that was, that was what God had called him to do.
He was supposed to deliver God's people from
the hand of the Philistines.
He ends up dying at the hand of the Philistines.
Instead, not only that, the Philistines
rein invaded the land because of it.
It was almost as if everything reset back to square one,
that Saul was called
to drive the Philistines outta the land.
And in the process of doing so, now it's reverted back
to the way it was to begin with.
They're back in the land. The people are scared.
The script got flipped here.
What Saul was supposed to do ended up dying at their hands.
Terrible consequence of his rebellion.
And so Saul's death was tragic
because it was not what he was supposed to do.
But also it was tragic
because it was inflicted and you saw it here.
His death was self-inflicted.
The text says that he was badly wounded by the archers,
but that didn't kill him.
Yet. He knew he was so badly wounded.
He knew he, there was no way he was walking
outta this battle alive.
And so he turns to his armor bearer, the man fighting
with him, carrying his stuff.
He turns to him and says, you finished the job.
But that man feared God enough, said,
I'm not touching God's anointed.
And so Saul ended up doing it himself
again, tragic, right?
And notice the Bible nowhere approves of what Saul did here,
it's merely stating the facts.
God's word never commends suicide.
In fact, the Bible views life as a gift from the Lord.
That because we are as humans made in the image of God,
it is unlawful to take life in a prohibited kind of way,
whether that's you or someone else there it.
It's not what God designs us to do.
But what I wanna focus on here is not the
means of Saul's death.
I wanna focus more on the fact that Saul didn't have
to die in the first place.
I mean, just think back after he first turned away from God,
chapter 13, his rebellion against God.
The whole trajectory of his life was a downward spiral,
culminating in this.
Yet it didn't have to be that way.
Remember, like, just think hypothetically,
if Saul at the first step would've turned away from his
rebellion, turned back his heart to God, trusting,
having faith in the Lord,
things could have been very different.
Yet he persisted in his rebellion.
He continued down the path of not worshiping the Lord,
of using and abusing his power, his position for himself.
All of that led to his eventual downfall.
It's tragic, but
there's one more piece to this tragedy that interestingly,
is that Saul's death actually came full circle.
There's some things here that show us that his death was,
was the completion of a circle in the text.
So think back to chapter four.
There's this battle where the Philistines win
and they capture the Ark of the Covenant, the symbol
of God's presence with his people.
Where did they take it? They took it to their temple Dayon.
Remember that was the statue
that the Ark of the Covenant was there.
And they woke up in the morning and it's
laid down face first.
Eventually the next morning, heads cut off all this stuff
that God was like, Hey, Uhuh, this, this isn't gonna work.
Where did they take Saul's armor here in Chapter
31 to their temple.
See, back then it was a symbol that
our God is stronger than yours.
Look, we won. And so we're taking your stuff to our temple.
'cause our God is stronger. Now,
we saw the first time that didn't work.
'cause the Ark of the Covenant, God's presence said, nuh,
this didn't happen in here.
Was God gonna let this one slide?
The armor of Saul, the king
of Israel is now in the temple of asteroids.
Is God gonna let that, let that slide.
We'll, actually, we'll see. Not till this fall.
We go into Second Samuel. When David steps up into
leadership, we'll see how that goes for the Philistines.
Just spoiler alert, they lose Anyway.
Um, but, but just think about that, right?
This is the tragedy. There's parallels here.
There's a cir there's a full circle moment to Eli.
You remember Eli, Eli was the,
the priest at the beginning of the book.
He was foolish, wasn't a good dad.
He had really, really wicked sons who were also priests.
And he just let 'em do whatever they wanted.
In that same battle, in chapter four,
Eli's sons died in the battle.
When Eli heard about his sons dying
in battle, what did he do?
He fell over dead as well.
It was God's judgment finally coming on.
Eli and his sons that had been promised.
You see parallels here, chapter 31, Saul finally
receives the full judgment of God in his death.
Who dies with him? His sons died.
Even this godly son, Jonathan, David's best friend that,
that they all got caught up in the judgment brought on Saul.
It's a full circle moment that Saul has equated in a sense
with Eli as wicked in both cases.
And there's one more full circle moment here.
It's interesting to watch who was it who courageously came
and, and re recovered the bodies of Saul and his sons
and took them back.
And in a way to try to honor the king
and the anointed one, who was it?
It was the men of Jesh Gilead.
Now, why is that significant?
That was where that, that area of Israel was, where
Saul had accomplished his first military
victory back in chapter 11.
And if you go read chapter 11, Saul in the victory says,
Hey, God brought victory to our land.
God was the one who won this.
And here at the end,
after persistently disobeying God over
and over, not trusting God here he dies
and is buried in the same location
that he won the first military battle.
First, like how far he's fallen, right?
He's like, God won the battle for us.
And now he doesn't even acknowledge God and loses
and ends up being buried at the same location,
probably under the tree that he used to sit at
and judgment full circle
how far he's fallen.
Now, here's what's interesting.
That's how first Samuel ends. Like it just stops.
Somebody asked me earlier, like, did, did I dress
up for Saul's funeral?
Is that kind of like, that's kinda
what this, this ends like, right?
It's just we're done.
Well, now we have to understand something about the Bible.
Remember this, that, that the Bible we hold in our hands.
It was not originally written in the verse chapter section
book format like we have today, right?
You look at this and
you, you know what it looks like, right?
Maybe you're scrolling through
and you see the verse numbers, chapters, headings,
names, and all these things.
Like it wasn't originally, we built most
of this in the last couple hundred years.
It wasn't originally like that.
The way it was originally put together, specifically first
and second Samuel, was
that it was one whole unit, right?
So it was like Samuel, it wasn't first, second,
it was Samuel, the words of Samuel and you.
So you, you can see how we have separated them out.
But what that means is that in a sense,
the narrative does not stop.
We think First Samuel ends.
Okay, well that kind of cliffed off the end, right?
No, it is a self-contained section.
It ends with Saul's death. But notice something.
Just turn one page to the right.
Maybe just scroll a little bit below.
Maybe it's on the same page you're looking at.
Look at Second Samuel, just the very first verse.
Second Samuel chapter one verse one. Look at this.
After the death of Saul,
when David had returned from striking down the Amalekites,
David remained two days in Ziklag.
There's no break, right? The narrative just continued.
Like it just kept going.
I've said this a few times, said it already this morning
in the fall, starting in August, we're gonna start
with second Samuel and we're gonna continue the story.
We need to see what David was really like as the king.
We're gonna compare and contrast Saul and David again.
But this is, this is gonna come
and we're gonna continue the story starting in August.
But what I thought would be really helpful for us today,
since First Samuel ends kind of weird like that,
to pick up some of how David responded to Saul's death.
Like it's instructive for us to understand like how did,
how did David, this guy who was supposed to be the king,
both anointed, how did David respond
Again, Saul and David
contrast, and we're gonna see it a lot here.
So now what we're gonna see is the kingly response by David.
Again, kingly is not a real word we use
very often, but you'll see what I mean.
Like David acting like the king.
How was his response as the transition's happening?
David's been growing into the role.
David's now stepping into the role
he's proven himself worthy.
How would he respond to Saul's death?
Well, the narrative actually portrays this.
You remember a couple weeks ago we looked at chapter 30.
This is what David was doing around the same time
that Saul was going to the Necromancer
and fighting this battle with the Philistines.
This is what David was doing, chapter 30.
And here in verse one, it repeats that.
It reiterates that, that this is what David was doing.
At the same time, Saul's battling and and dying.
Why is that important? Well, first,
because that puts David somewhere else that he can stand
with clean conscience.
That he had nothing to do with Saul's death, right?
He, he was clean. Nobody could accuse him of anything.
He's over here fighting the Amalekites
and Ziklag like he, he's over there,
Saul's over there fighting the Philistines.
David had nothing to do with it.
Nobody could accuse him that he was manipulative
and trying to fight battles for himself.
He was just doing what he was called to do.
Saul died because God judged him.
But it also proves, second, it proves
that David was truly acting like the king.
'cause Saul's fighting battles for himself.
He's trying to preserve his kingdom.
David over here, he's defending people.
He's delivering people from slavery.
He's providing financial help
for people who aren't even at the battle.
He's doing things that kings do. He's acting like a king.
He's proving himself worthy As the king.
But here's what we can't miss. We can't miss that.
That all happened because David had finally fully
surrendered to the Lord.
Remember, David has this habit.
We've seen this throughout one Samuel, right?
David has this habit of kind of like,
I'm gonna use my own cunning ability.
I'm gonna use my own speaking ability.
I'm gonna act a certain way,
or I'm gonna get these people on my side to try
to manipulate the circumstances so
that he gets what he wants.
And what it brought over and over again was trouble.
Trouble for him, trouble for others.
He kept trying himself to, to solve the equation.
It brought problems when he finally said, God,
this is yours, chapter 30, God, this is yours.
What happened? God brought victory.
God showed up to bring the victory that he needed.
When David trusted him to work it out, God said, I got you.
Well, that leads to a pretty clear application question
for us today, doesn't it?
Will you trust God to resolve your problems?
Will you trust God
To resolve the problems you're facing day to day?
Big picture, small picture, whatever it is.
Will you trust that God is going to resolve them?
Or will you try to take matters into your own hands?
Now you have a responsibility to act
and what God says to do, yes, I'm not saying you don't.
You sit on the couch and God does everything I'm saying.
You try to control the situation.
If I've learned anything in my life, if,
if we've learned anything through one Samuel, it's
that when we choose to be the king of our own lives,
it goes south really fast.
When we try to take control, when we try to,
to allow our own abilities, resources to manage
and manipulate and control, it goes bad.
But if we stop
and allow God to reign as king as he is,
things begin to work a little better.
Not perfectly, but things work out exactly as God wants them
to work out for us.
He solves the problems for us.
We get in trouble when we try
to take charge when he's in charge.
That's his plan.
So will you trust that God's gonna work it out
or will you try to take it yourself?
That's a day by day moment by moment.
Question every one of us has to answer.
David shows us what happens when we do
answer that question with faith.
So David responded like a king
first in the way he trusted God, allowing that to happen,
he followed God's plan.
He ends up in Ziklag instead of at Gilboa.
And he's not accused of He He's, he's trusting God
and he's obeying God and it works well.
But here's the second way that he responded like a king
to all of this, is that he was grieved
by Saul's death, the anointed one.
Both of them were anointed by God as the king.
David knew that David treated him like that.
I can't touch the Lord's anointed.
And yet, when Saul died, he was deeply
grieved by it.
Continue down in Second Samuel chapter one,
look at verses 11 and 12.
This is when David heard of Saul's death
for the first time, verse 11.
Then David took hold of his clothes and tore them.
That's a sign of grief.
And so did all the men who were with him, and they mourned
and wept and fasted until evening for Saul
and for Jonathan, his son,
and for the people of the Lord, for the house of Israel,
because they had fallen by the sword
like a deep grief, right?
It wasn't just a few tears shed, it wasn't just kinda like,
ah, that's, that's tough.
But it was physical actions.
You can imagine he's even throwing ashes on his head.
That was a sign of grief that they're mourning, deeply
wounded by the fact that Saul and Jonathan
and the men had had died.
In fact, David, we know David's a great musician, right?
Wrote us a ton of the Psalms.
He writes a song of lament about this whole situation.
You can go read it later in the second half of chapter one.
It's just his profound pouring out of lament of lamentation,
of grief, of mourning over this situation.
In fact, three times it repeats the refrain,
how the mighty have fallen, how the mighty have fallen,
how the mighty have fallen like this
monumental king of Israel, one king, such high status,
such hope, how the mighty have fallen
both in death and in the way they followed.
God, it it's profound.
David's wrestling with the loss and he's writing this song
and it's really, really deep.
But let's be clear about something here. Think about this.
Who was David writing that about?
He was writing it about Jonathan, his best friend,
like the man who stood
with him when nobody else would, right?
That's who he's writing it about.
He's craved over his best friend dying.
Of course he would be.
But notice he's also responding like this about
Saul, the one who
multiple times tried to kill David, who
for years had him on the run,
who hunted David like he was a wild animal.
David is writing this song. David is responding.
David is grieving about a man who was trying to kill him,
and now that man's dead and David is deeply impacted.
There's a second question here, right?
Can you love your enemies like that?
I mean, just ask yourself the question you.
You can think of the person that's your enemy, right?
Whatever. Some may project out.
Somebody who's trying to take your very life over and over
and you're running in fear.
You're living in threat all the time.
You find out that that person's dead.
How would you respond? Like in a sense,
I think most of us would probably be like celebrating.
We'd be happy with man. Woo. Finally free of that mess.
Like, oh, thank you for the victory you gave me.
God, man, I'm so thankful
that I don't have that problem anymore.
Wow, I am so much more free.
Would you respond that way?
It's kinda like how Saul,
imagine if David, imagine if it's flipped.
Imagine if David was the one who died, Saul,
whose laser focused on eliminating everyone who opposed him.
How would he respond? He'd be like, yes.
Finally, I got him, man, he'd been chasing him for years.
I finally got him.
David's gone. The problem is solved.
Would You respond like that?
Or Do you respond to those
who oppose you more like
David, who
grieved, mourned the death
Of his Oppressor?
Do you respond like Stephen?
Remember Stephen in Acts chapter seven,
the first Christian martyr, he stands up in front
of the religious elites and he, he's asked these questions.
They're like, why are you doing this?
Why do you believe this? And Stephen's like, Hey, listen,
lemme tell you why I believe this.
Because he goes back to the very beginning
and tells him throughout the entire history of Israel,
and he walks through and he says,
Jesus is the fulfillment of all of that.
That's why I worship him.
He died and resurrected and you killed him.
But I'm worshiping him as a resurrected savior.
And what they do in response
is they start throwing heavy stones on him
to crush him to death.
And As he is being
Executed, He looks to heaven
and he says, father, forgive them.
They don't know what they're doing.
Do you respond like that
To your enemy?
Listen, there is only one way
that we can respond like that.
There's only one way it is possible for you
and for me to love our enemies like that.
There is no other way apart from being transformed
by the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus Christ for you.
The one who on the cross himself looked at his executors
and said, father, forgive them
for they don't know what they're doing.
There's only one way. It's only through.
There's only one way we can avoid a life of vengeance.
There's only one way we can avoid an eye
for an eye, a tooth for a tooth.
That's the way the world works, right? Revenge, vengeance.
That's how the way of our flesh pushes us towards that.
There's only one way we can sacrifice for others is
through Jesus Christ who sacrificed for us.
See, when you place your faith in him,
he takes away your self focused heart of stone.
That's only about vengeance. It's only about self.
He takes that away, gives you a heart of flesh
that's now focused on him.
It's a new heart able to now love your enemies
and to love him with all that you are.
And really, listen. That's what the whole book
of one Samuels has been pointing us to.
And Jesus would agree with this
because as much as we've seen this contrast between Saul
and David, and we've learned a lot from that, yes,
but neither of them was perfect.
Neither of them were a perfect king.
We'll see it, especially in the fall with dead.
Neither were a perfect king that can sustain
handling our salvation.
So really what this is pointing us to, for them forward,
for us, we know now,
but it's pointing us towards someone who's coming later
to David's greater son, who would be the king once
and for all the Messiah whose name is Jesus Christ.
That's what first Samuel points us to.
And here's how we're gonna get there. Watch this.
This is interesting exercise.
We're not just gonna contrast Saul and David.
Let's contrast Saul and Jesus.
Saul the fallen king with Jesus, the perfect king.
And here's what this will do. It'll show us
even more clearly the gospel hope we
have in him.
Like this is what we're gonna look at the gospel, hope
through the lens of contrast.
We'll watch this gospel hope take off.
We're gonna look at parallels here. This is so interesting.
Watch this one, Saul. Think.
Think about Saul, especially at the end.
Think about Saul's life. Where did he die?
He died here. Chapter 31 says on Mount Gilboa.
That was his final life breath.
But then you think about Saul, all of
what we learned about him, he was a selfish king.
He was living and dying even for himself.
It was all to try to preserve his own kingdom.
That was Saul's focus.
He never came to grips with the reality
that David was the one to replace him.
That God had said, here's what's going to happen.
Saul could never accept it.
He was so focused on himself clinging to this throne
and his own little kingdom.
That's what he wanted more than anything else.
That was Saul. But now contrast that with Jesus.
Watch this. Jesus lived his whole life perfectly.
Watch this. Where did Jesus die?
Mount Gha
as a selfless king
for others, wanting to
magnify his father's kingdom.
Right? Do you see this? You see the parallels here.
The the fallen king, imperfect king Saul
and all of those things, and the perfect king Jesus.
You see how the parallels work.
I'm not just making this stuff up. Let me show you.
God's word says all of these things. John 17, four.
Jesus prayed to his father.
He said, I glorified you on earth
having accomplished the work that you gave me to do.
He was focused on his father's kingdom
above his own kingdom.
Mark 10 45.
The son of man did not come to be served,
but to serve and to give his life as a ransom for many.
He wasn't here for himself. He was here for others.
In Romans five, eight, God demonstrates his own love
for us in this, that while we were still sinners,
Christ died for us enemies.
Christ died for his enemies. God showed his love in that.
Again, Saul died.
Mount Gilboa, a selfish king for himself, trying
to preserve his own kingdom, which really, listen,
that's every one of us, right?
We're all about ourselves. We're all about our own kingdom.
We're all about dying for self, not for anyone else.
Like this is how we are to do this.
We, we are a flesh love being like Saul.
But Jesus died on Mount Gha, a selfless king
for others, wanting to preserve his father's
and magnify his father's kingdom.
Is that not good news that we have a perfect king like that?
Who does it for us? Like we have a savior
king, not just a king.
We have a savior king who paid with his blood, our penalty
that we, our debt that we deserve to owe,
that we should pay for.
God paid it through his son's life.
You know that like in our place for our good,
we have someone who looked at us,
his enemies and said,
I want him in my family.
I want her in my family.
And I'm gonna pay for them to be in my family
with my son's life.
Like that's love folks.
That is mega, super above the chart love.
That's why he did it. We could never pay our own penalty.
We would deserve wrath. We deserved it.
We could never pay the price to get out of that.
And we would fall short. You would fall short. I fall short.
Every one of us fall short in this.
There's only one way to the father
through this perfect savior king that we have
who paid it all for us.
And again, you know why he did it.
He did it because he loves you
immensely as his enemy.
He loves you. And now you are a part of his family by faith.
Let's reflect on that now, if you would bow your heads
with me and close your eyes just to focus our hearts on
what he wants to do in us.
Now,
as the worship leaders are coming out, we're,
we're at this place with this hard text, this hard passage,
but, but really,
have you ever seen the love of God like that before?
Maybe you've been to church, maybe
you've been a good person.
Maybe you're around things
enough that you think you're good.
You think you're good enough, you think you've done enough.
There's no way to be good enough.
You have to be perfect. You've already blown it,
and yet you have a substitute who was perfect
for you and his willing
self-sacrifice for your good,
even when you don't deserve it.
Even when you could never pay him back.
That's his love for you.
Do you grasp that?
You understand that you feel that
maybe you've never rested in that love before
and you're seeing today like this is, this is what I need.
I I I can't make it. I I know I can. I'm exhausted.
I need that love. Simply run to him right now.
Jesus, I need you. I'm, I know I'm a sinner.
I know I can't make it. I need you. You did it all for me.
Save me.
We'd love to hear about that if you right now do that.
But, but also maybe, maybe you're like me this morning, I,
I woke up kind
of just not really excited about that.
Love of God wasn't wrong, wasn't bad.
I wasn't doing anything. I was just kind of lost
that affection.
And it wasn't until this morning first service
that I was able to preach this gospel to myself
and read it and hear it and
understand it and sing it and all that.
Like that's what began to stir my affection.
So this service has been totally different
for me than the first one was.
And maybe that's what you walked in here with.
You don't know you like I I just don't feel it right now.
Okay? Ask, come to him right now.
Ask God to just stir your affections for him right now.
You've heard it and we need it over and over and over again.
It sounds repetitive. We preach the same message every week.
We need it every week.
Just stir your God.
Restore to me as Psalm 51 says, restore to me the joy
of your salvation.
That I would then return that joy with love
for you and love in every way.
Just pray that to him as we sing this.
Be reminded of his love for you, that you could be able
to love him back.